6 25 on your monday morning making sure
you know about this big squeeze
95 515 east side of the spaghetti bowl
it's part of a 40 million dollar fix up
project but both directions the 95 515
down to two lanes
for the next year and a half now the
southbound side already started that was
last night
northbounders you are okay today but
late tomorrow night the squeeze starts
for you
because the nevada department of
transportation wants you to know as much
about this project as you can
they've gone all in there's a website
i515project.com
then all using the name i 515 fix lv
there are twitter facebook and instagram
pages
you can sign up for text alerts say the
internet and all that social media is
not your thing and that's also got
regular phone numbers you can call or
text with service in both english and on
espanol
ramp closures in the repaving area we
got the specifics on those
as well as detours all the info from
today's report can be found in the
online version of this
in fact all of our stories at
8newsnow.com click traffic
then driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
8 news now dot com